herzlich willkommen so sammelt also
normalerweise stehe ich nicht vor der
kamera
das hat einen besonderen grund weil
unsere sally meine frau und unsere mama
die hat geburtstag und wir haben uns
etwas vormachen was sollen wir eine
lehrerin einer youtube in einem
multitalent
denn schenken über machen oder tun
jetzt haben wir zugelegt wir machen ein
youtube video zusammen mit dass inter
samira wir waren für die mama an einem
geburtstags punkt und dann dürfen wir
einfach danke sagen für die letzte zeit
oder dafür dass sie immer für uns da ist
wir versuchen jetzt einfach an wieder zu
machen wie das andere und mache ich muss
auch selber schneiden also haben
nachsicht mit uns zwei und wir möchten
dass sie einfach danke sagen das was sie
macht was ich für uns macht wie sie für
uns da ist
ich glaube so gut wie wir zwar jetzt
kennt unseres händen niemand ich sehe
hat viele talente talente wie ihr
vielleicht noch alle gar nicht wissen wo
sie noch gar nicht gezeigt hat talente
wie auch andere leute haben aber nicht
in dieser häufigkeit und in dieser menge
diese hatten sie kocht sie backen sie
steht abends um 10 uhr auf und sagt dann
einfach schatz ich höre jetzt ein kuchen
backen
ich möchte jetzt das machen sie malt
wundervolle bilder
sie schminkt ihre freundinnen für die
hochzeit sie baut möbels alle möbel im
haus hat sich jetzt aufgebaut sind
talente wie sie hat sie hat in ihrem
gehirn studium und kind auf die welt
gebracht sie hat ja studium durchgezogen
ohne pause zu machen
sie hatten youtube kanal hochgezogen
jetzt inzwischen 18 millionen publikum
es ist einfach wahnsinn was die band
nach all dem hat sie immer noch zeit für
uns und es ist wunderschön mit ihr das
leben zu gestalten
es ist wunderschön auch sie als mama zu
haben habe ich recht etc und wie gesagt
vielen vielen dank seminar happy
birthday nicht nur von uns wir haben
über freunde haben hier auch eine kleine
message geschickten und diese ist du
jetzt und danach folgt dann von mir auch
ich fange an dir mal cool zu backen weiß
ich bin in der küche ging eine null
ich habe nur einmal für diese kopf
danach hatte ich mich verliebt dann
erhalte damit aufgegeben weil man so oft
am schönsten ist und wie gesagt also
happy birthday liebe seele schauen dass
wir an
ich wünsche dir alles gute zum
geburtstag
und das so weit er noch für mich ein
paar torten backen und gibt es am ihre
akkus verlieren sich diabetiker wichtig
jede torte aufrufen
alles alles gute und bis hin zur
premiere von 3
hallo zählt alles gute zum geburtstag
wünsche ich dir auch aus berlin
lass dich feiern du toll und wir freuen
uns auf lange lange lange jahre mit
deinen taten bisher linie der eko fresh
alles alles gute zum geburtstag und ich
freue mich die torten hast ja selber
irgendwann kriegt vielleicht auch ein
stück sally was du geile dingen alles
gute zum geburtstag und zwar ich hätte
eine freie gehängt bist du denn
eigentlich geworden
ich weiß nichts hast du den zum
geburtstag und würde jetzt gern kuchen
backen glaubt es kannst noch so ein
bisschen besser als ich feier schön
genießt seine zeit und es nicht zu viel
kuchen mit diesen worten hallo sally ich
wünsche dir von herzen alles erdenklich
gute zum geburtstag vor allen dingen
gesundheit zufrieden
glück und dass vielleicht mal ein
kleiner schnitt geben die für mich raus
das wünsche ich dir von herzen rein
markus babbel hallo sally ich wünsche
dir alles liebe und gute zum geburtstag
ich hoffe dass wir bald die möglichkeit
haben uns persönlich kennenzulernen und
ich liebe deine videos bleib so wie du
bist und genießt auf den ehrentag hey
liebe felhi ich wünsche dir alles alles
liebe zum geburtstag viel glück viel
zufriedenheit und gesundheit natürlich
du liest den tag bestimmen mit einer
zuckersüßen familie ich wünsche dir ganz
ganz viel spaß an einem besonderen tag
der geburt seien heute nicht pressen
liebe sally alles gute zum geburtstag
und einer schwester und von einem
sportler
und jetzt kommt für dich noch ein bomben
video nur für dich sli baskett abstrus
alles gute zum geburtstag wollte ich dir
auf diesem wege mit geben
die brille ist nötig glaubt mir ich sehe
nicht gut ich bin voll fertig diese
typische sommergrippe die man in
deutschland bekommt bekommen dort mal
seit gestern und er ja ich sag mal so
abonniert diesen channel so voll die
routine schon gerollt stimmung server
aber die rennen ja
youtube sucht dies mach's gut und ich
freue mich dem nächsten dabei die ein
kurzes muri und die kleine
überdimensionale frisur wie immer hallo
sally ich bin noch kein promi aber
trotzdem darf ich meine allerliebsten
schnitte doch alles gute zum geburtstag
wünschen ich dann direkt für alles
irgendwie haben unsere wege sich doch
gefunden
von klein bis jetzt ich wünsche von
herzen nicht nur das beste
bleib so wie du bist kennst mich doch
ich bin krank ich will dass du hast
richtig schwindlig wird
inschallah wenn wir noch sehr viele
lange und lustige schöne dicke tage
miteinander haben
ich küsse deine füße ordner für alles
was ich mit euch bis jetzt mitmachen
durfte und inschallah hat ist niemals
auf küsst eine kleine samira und diese
leiche im keller will ich leb geworden
habe ich verspreche euch wenn ich
zurückkomme vom libanon dann inschallah
ich mich nicht rasiert bleib wie du bist
eine sehr gute freundin von mir hat
heute geburtstag
sally stehe jetzt hier in sonthofen
als wir beide noch im kindergarten
machen
da haben wir beide noch porten gebacken
im sonst was war deine erste torte weißt
du noch damals wir beide holen
du hast es geschafft
ich hab noch nicht mal wasser im
wasserkocher war zu kommen du bist jetzt
dort entgegen
ich würde gerne was ich will sie auf
jeden fall alles gute zu deinem
geburtstag nächste mal wenn du nach
berlin kommst ja bringen wir mal so ein
stück auf geburtstags dort auch wenn sie
grün ist es trotzdem weil ich weiß ganz
genau mit den besten in
berlin-brandenburg ja ok in deutschland
auch alles alles gute zum geburtstag
viel schlafen haben
vielen dank an euch alle die serie
zwischen den tag freuen
es wird eine tolle überraschung für sie
seien die sage ich wir machen jetzt das
ganz einfaches also was einfach an was
man machen kann
genauso haben wir ein rezept von der
seele geschnappt und zwar das ist der
saftige schoko nuss kuchen in kastenform
das ist das hier das ist ein fasten
da ist ganz einfach da wird nur mit dem
schwank becher gemacht bis jetzt und
hier sind die zutaten nicht sagt er
der kuchen ist ganz einfach der trick an
der ganze geschichte ist einfach man hat
hier ein becher und ich habe jetzt zum
beispiel dass das rezept von der seligen
ob die schreibt jetzt in ordnung
und das rezept ist ganz einfach es sind
immer ein mensch man ein mega zucker
eine packung ein bisschen trotzig popo
das eiweiß ist schon da
ua
okay aber nicht in den kuchen
das hat mich geschickt wie gesagt es ist
immer ein wenn wir nicht mehr reine
wussten ja okay also fangen wir an
wir brauchen vier eier und 24 machst du
das
können sie da rein war
jetzt richtig machen
jetzt können wir die die eier die eier
kommen jetzt in die schüssel um schüssel
was jetzt tut mir die vier eier immer
wie in die schüssel reinmachen geschätzt
okay okay jetzt zum rhein becher sparen
ein becher zucker jetzt wollen wir jetzt
ein ca ich hoffe wir machen das richtig
ein päckchen vanillezucker 1 päckchen
vanillezucker ungefähr
diese erst einmal dreht man im schatten
ein becher mail
dann nehmen wir wieder diesen pkw diesen
becher wein ist mir auch weg und dann
brauchen wir ein trucker jetzt machen
wir einbrechen müsse er hatte schon
gemalt
dann nimmt die selmer ganze nüsse und
mal selber weil das aroma dann besser
ist
wir müssen sauber machen
wir haben ein bisschen schatz ein becher
öl jetzt weiß ja nicht ob olivenöl oder
oder sonnenblumenöl geschmacksneutral
ist natürlich ist olivenöl das
sonnenblumenöl
also lassen wir uns vom olivenöl seite
dann nehmen wir jetzt sonnenblumen volt
und als beim sonnenblumenöl brauchen wir
auch einen becher hat aber nicht so er
aber aber nicht so reich fallen lassen
okay okay plumpsen lassen langsam rein
machen schön noch ein halbes päckchen
backpulver und zwar haben wir hier schon
von halb ich wusste sitzen halbes
päckchen erstmal rein schatz du mir erst
kurzfristig räumen
und wenn wir aufgeräumt haben dann den
teig jetzt haben wir ein bisschen
aufgeräumt
damit sich so übel aussieht
die samira und ich wir werden jetzt den
teig verrühren in der zwischenzeit könnt
den backofen vorheizen auf 180 grad
und wie gesagt wir wollen wir hören
jetzt diesen teil einer kick schnitt
machen oder in einer anderen
küchenmaschinen wie auch immer wir
machen es ist halt ein bisschen helfen
aber nicht den findigen haushalts als
wäre jetzt irgendwie fertig weiß ich wie
man aussieht der fertiger ist jetzt wenn
wir dieses kastenform richtig und jetzt
ist alles ist unprofessionell aus hast
du mir nicht hier machen ich habe mir
ist ein professioneller als ich und
jetzt mir alles zusammen
alles was ich gleich ob schuljungen was
ich jetzt mal vielleicht mangel könnte
ist ein bisschen 10.3 machen genau das
mache jetzt noch da trainer für mich
sein rezept kurzem sender ab und 19
hier habe ich noch ein bisschen 10
das habe ich jetzt ich mag sie
ich denke zu erreichen
samira hat jetzt aufgegeben in dem kohl
zu backen sie nachschuss lieber einen
kuchen
ich probier mal er schmeckt richtig
lecker geschmeckt sowie zur wiesn
pudding und jetzt tut mir hier ein
großes vor mit kuchen
ich glaube ich bin da lieber pips
nächsten jahr die ablagen dann schlägt
alles ab süße maus zwei sich erstmal
auch mal als man die arbeit des heilig
ist ist alles so einfach aus wenn es
seriös gemacht
sie sagt auch wir machen das ist alles
einfach sie vielleicht und zwar bis
jetzt so aus ich habe den ganzen boden
ist jetzt bedeckt und kuchen
dass ich jetzt bist du wenig aus ich
weiß nicht wo ein bisschen hoch gehen
nicht alle ziemlich kleiner kuchen
bilder gucken
ich weiß dass das nicht mehr versteht
vielleicht ist wie beton anmischen
morgen liegt solches richtig gab die
kerze erst nach dem backen drauf oder
kerze jetzt nach dem backen jetzt die
kerze rein machen aber dann schmilzt sie
im ofen jobs vorgeheizt ich tue das
jetzt ungefähr mitte vom ofen und da
wird dann der stunde gebacken
wie gesagt so sieht der kugel ins aus so
tue jetzt einen ofen und mal schauen was
passiert
so sieht der kuchen aus ich hoffe ihr
seht es
ich habe jetzt mehrmals die stimmung
gemacht so wie ich habe ein paar mal
mehr gebrauchen als die seele wie ihr
seht und wie gesagt der es fertig was
ich jetzt noch gern hätte ist ich würde
zum beispiel gerne auf dieses
schokokuchen ist er richtig schokolade
schmeckt so richtig sollte saftig ist
man da ist auch schon saftig würde ich
noch keine schoko schicht über den
kuchen machen
jetzt nehme ich einfach die kuvertüre
und machen es ganz einfach ich würde es
noch klein schneiden hier in inzell ist
mittelrhein geben und dann ist einfach
kurz in den backofen mit damit der nach
hitze vom backofen der schokolade
schmelzen den juke wohnhaus holen und
dann über gießen oder to san mir auch
nicht den kuchen noch dekorieren so weiß
natürlich nicht ich lasse mir mal ganz
kurz abkühlen am besten wir stellen mal
zur seite
ok jetzt haben wir es besser gemacht es
dann süßes klein schneiden damit es
besser schmilzt schneller schmilzt ich
glaube dass deswegen machen sie es keine
ahnung warum
thomas klein gemacht und zwar leider
leider jetzt dichtesten für ein paar
minuten im backofen
klassisch schön schmilzt und damit wir
mit den kuchen übergießen
jetzt habe ich die schokolade
geschmolzen ich weiss nicht wie dies die
säle macht ich habe es einmal eine
packung eingestellte nach hitze und
jetzt ist sie flüssig und jetzt tue
schon denn schon komisch und gestürzt
habe damit einschmieren
weil die samira und ich wir möchten
daher ist noch dekorieren für die mama
der manager
schatz was ich mache das ist ich gebe
dir immer fan die hand okay
jetzt haben wir hier noch pub
dekoartikel wir auch machen aber nur
eine grau ok hatte damals falsch gemacht
wieder muss man da müssen wir die
kletterer hier reinstecken
genau so ist das naja
zusammen das war es von uns zwei wir
haben jetzt mal ein kuchen gebacken
wie gesagt alles alles liebe für uns
zwei mal gespannt wie das jetzt hier
findest du liebst du mich liebst du mich
liebst du mich auch okay und wer hat
geburtstag
die macht das die toten und diffamiere